PROFESSOR: So we'll look at
the Schrodinger equation.
We're going to work
for bound states.
We could work with
scattering states
in spherical coordinates,
but it's usually
done in advanced courses.
The most important
thing is the calculation
of the bound states.
This is kind of a neat
part of quantum mechanics
because, in a sense, you get
accustomed in quantum mechanics
about uncertainties.
You cannot predict the
probability that the photon
will go through this branch
of the interferometer or this
other probability.
You can't be sure and all this.
But here you get
the energy levels.
And you get the
exact energy level.
So it's a nice thing that,
in quantum mechanics,
energy levels are things
that you calculate exactly.
Of course, when
you try to measure
energy levels experimentally,
the uncertainties arise again.
You get the photon
of some energy
and then there's some energy
time uncertainty or something
like that, that can bother you.
But the end result
is that these systems
have beautifully the
term in fixed numbers
called energy levels.
And that's what we're aiming at.
It's a nice thing because it's
the most physical example.
It has many applications.
The energy levels
of hydrogen atom.
The more you study,
the more complicated
they are because you can
include fine effects,
like the effects of the
spins of the particles.
What does it do?
The specs of relativity.
All kinds of things
you can put in and do
more and more accurate results.
So it's really
unbelievable how much
you can learn with the fine
spectrum of the hydrogen atom.
Our equation is minus h squared
over 2m, d second dr squared--
the radial equation--
plus h squared l times l
plus 1 over 2mr squared
minus ze squared over r,
u is equal to Eu.
So this is the radial equation.
Remember it was
like the Schrodinger
equation for a variable u.
And the wave function was u
over r times psi lm or Ylm,
actually, a spherical harmonic.
Here I could have
labeled u with E and l
because could
certainly u depends--
u is u of r.
And u depends on the energy
that we're going to get.
And it will depend
on l that is there,
in the differential equation.
This is the effective potential
that we discussed before.
It was the original
potential to which you
add the centrifugal barrier.
And what are you
supposed to solve here?
You're supposed to
solve for l equals 0.
To find some states
for a, go one, two,
three, four, infinity.
You should find all the
energy levels of this thing.
So the wave function is
psi of r theta and phi
will be this u of r over r
times Ylm of theta and phi.
And, in fact, plugging that
into the Schrodinger equation
was what gave us
this radial equation.
So this was called
the radial equation,
which we talked about,
but never quite solved it
for any particular example.
OK.
As you know, we
like, in this course,
to get rid of units
and constants,
so our first step is to
replace r by a unit free x.
And we have the right quantity.
a0.
a0 would be the perfect thing.
So you-- if you
do that, you will
be able to clean up the units.
But if you do that,
you might not quite
be able to clean up the
z from all the places
that you would like
to clean it up.
So we can improve that--
maybe it's not too obvious.
--by putting a 2 over z Here.
z has no units, of course,
so that you would probably
do by trial and error.
You would say, well I want
to get rid of the z as well.
And I have it in this form.
And you will see
how it works out.
So at this moment, I have
to plug r into this equation
and just clean it up.
And what should happen is that
everything, all the units,
should give you a factor
with units of energy.
Because at the end of the--
whatever is left, it's
not going to have units.
Everything out must
have units of energy.
So this takes about
one line to do.
I'll skip some algebra
on these things.
I'll try to post
notes soon on this.
So if you leave a
line you could do
that calculation for yourselves
and it might be worth it.
The claim is that
we get 2z squared e
squared over a0,
multiplying minus d second,
dx squared plus l times l
plus 1 over x squared minus 1
over x, times u, equals Eu.
That will be the
common factor that
will come out of everything
by the time you solve it.
And it has the units of
energy, as you can imagine.
e squared over a0
has a unit of energy.
So might as well move
that to the other side
to get the final form
of the equation, which
would be minus d second,
dx squared plus l times l
plus 1 over x squared,
minus 1 over x, u
is equal to minus
kappa squared u.
Where kappa squared is
going to be minus E over 2z
squared little e
squared over a0.
OK.
The trick on all
these things is to not
lose track of our variables.
And that-- it's a
little challenging.
So let me just re-emphasize
what's going on here.
We've passed from r
variables to u variables,
that we will still
do more things.
And we have a0 in
there, z in there,
and then the energy
is really encapsulated
by kappa squared here.
And this kappa is unit free.
So if you know kappa,
you know the energies.
That's what you
should be looking for.
Kappa is the thing you
want to figure out.
Knowing kappa is the same
as knowing their origins
because this is just a
constant that gives you
the scale of the energy.
So this is what
we want to solve.
And the equation doesn't
look all that complicated,
but it's actually not yet
that simple, unfortunately.
So we have to keep
working with it a bit.
So one reason you can see
that an equation like that
would not be too
simple, is to look at it
and see what kind of recursion
relation it would give you.
And that's a good thing
to look at the beginning.
And you say, OK here I'm going
to lower the number of powers
by two.
Here I'm going to lower the
number of powers by one.
And here I'm not going to
lower the number of powers.
You're gonna have three terms.
So it's not that simple
recursion relation,
which the next term is
determined by the previous one.
So that suggests you
better do some work still
with this equation to
simplify the situation.
And several things that
you can do-- one thing
is to look at the behavior of
the equation, near infinity,
near zero, and see if you
see patterns going on.
One thing we're
going to do is to--
which is not urgent,
but it's usually done.
And people do it
in different ways.
--is to look at x goes
to infinity and see what
the solutions may look like.
So as x goes to infinity, the
differential equation probably
can be approximated to keep this
storm to see how things vary.
And x goes to infinity.
Throw this, throw
this, and keep that.
So you would have d
second u dx squared is
equal to kappa squared.
So this suggests
that u goes like e
to the plus minus kappa x.
So exponential behavior.
e to the plus minus kappa x.
Ideally, of course,
for our solutions,
we would like the
minus one, but we
will see what the equations do.
Now this suggests, yet another
transformation that people do,
which is--
look, kappa is
dimensionless and we
had x that is unit free also.
So kappa has no
units, x has no units.
So let's move to yet
another variable.
We started with r being
proportionate to x.
And now we can put factors that
may help us without units here.
So I'm not suggesting
that this is something
that would occur to me,
if I'm doing this problem,
but it's certainly a
possible thing to do.
To say, OK, I'm going to
define now rho as kappa x.
And with x being
given by this, rho
would be 2 kappa z over a0 r.
So rho is going to
be my new coordinate.
I'm sorry, we've gone to x.
And now we've gone to rho,
a new variable over here.
So what happens to the
differential equation?
Well, it's going to
be a little better,
but in particular the solutions
may be a little better.
But here it is.
If you look at the
differential equation.
The differential equation here.
Think of moving the
kappa squared here below.
And then you see, immediately,
it fits perfectly well
in the first two terms.
So you get minus d second, d rho
squared plus l times l plus 1,
rho squared.
And here it doesn't
fit all that well.
You would have 1 kappa
leftover, so 1 over kappa rho, u
equals minus u.
Yes it's kind of suggestive.
The kappa has almost
disappeared from everywhere,
but it better not
disappear from everywhere.
If it would have
disappeared from everywhere
we would have been in problems
because the equation would've
not fixed the energy.
You see we're hoping that the
differential equation will have
additional solutions for
some values of the energy
and for the others no.
So the energy better
not disappear.
It came close to
disappearing, the kappa,
but it's still here,
so we're still OK.
And now, you will
say, OK, this is nice.
If you look at rho
going to infinity again.
It works as we wanted.
You get d second u, d rho
squared is equal to u.
And that means u goes to e
to the plus minus rho, which
is what inspired this.
And the other part
of the solution
is the solution at
near r going to 0.
Or your x going to 0
or near rho equal--
going to 0.
So near rho going to 0,
you have these two terms.
And we actually
did it last time.
We analyzed what was going on
with this equation last time.
Near rho equal to 0.
And we found out that u must
behave like rho to the l plus 1
for rho going to 0.
So it was from this two terms
the differential equation.
And for rho going to 0.
Remember the wave
function must vanish.
And how fast it should vanish?
Should vanish to this
power to the l plus 1.
OK.
So you know lots of things
about this function.
So first of all, that
this thing doesn't
have necessarily polynomial
solutions because it
behaves exponentially.
Moreover, you know it doesn't
start with constant plus rho
plus rho squared.
It starts with rho
to the l plus 1.
So it is pretty important
to see all these things
before you try to do a recursion
relation because recursion
relation might lead
you to funny things.
So here we go.
What do we do based on all this?
We try something better.
Which is-- we said u of rho, the
solution-- we're writing ansets
--is going to be rho
to the l plus 1, that
will have the right
behavior for rho going to 0.
An unknown function
w of rho times
e to the minus rho, which is
the right behavior we want.
Now there is no
assumption, whatsoever,
when you write in
ansets of this form.
You're just expressing
your knowledge.
Because at the end
of the day if rho--
if omega-- or w here,
actually, is undetermined.
This w will have an e to the
rho that cancels this factor.
And may be off with some
funny power that cancels this.
This is just a hope
that we're expressing
that by writing this
solution in this form,
this quantity may be simple.
Because we know this is present
in the solution for larger rho,
this is present for small
rho, well in between
we might have that.
And when you write
analysis of this form,
you hope for a simple
differential equation for w.
So what do we get?
We can plug that ansets into
the differential equation
that we already have
and see what happens.
And indeed that's what we'll do.
I'll skip the calculation.
In my notes, it
took me half a page
and I write big, so
it's not too long.
So what do we get?
You get an equation that
doesn't look that simple.
I'm sorry.
It just looks like a
step back, but it's not.
d second w, d rho squared plus
2 times l plus 1 minus rho.
Strange.
dw, d rho plus, 1 over kappa
minus 2 times l plus 1,
w equals 0.
OK.
Aesthetically, it looks worse.
Certainly that equation on
the left board looked nicer,
but actually it's pretty
good because, again, now look
at your recursion relation.
How will it be?
If you take some power--
fixed power.
Here you lose one power.
Here with the l plus 1 of
these, you lose one power.
Here you lose nothing.
And here you lose nothing.
So you have either one
power less or your power.
So it's a one step recursion
relation without the gap.
It's not like the
two steps that we
had for the harmonic oscillator,
for the Legendre polynomials.
Here is one step
recursion relation.
ak plus 1 determined by ak.
So we say, excuse
me to the equation,
you don't look that good,
but you're very solvable.
So we can proceed.